auf dem hambacher schloss wehte zum
aller ersten mal in der deutschen
geschichte eine fahne in
schwarz-rot-gold ende mai 1832 wurde sie
hinauf getragen bei der berühmten
protestveranstaltung dem hambacher fest
das kostbare original gibt es noch auch
wenn die farben verblassen sind das ist
unsere ursprungs kleine die erste
schwarz rot goldene fahne die getragen
wurde und beim hambacher fest 1832
damals nicht die deutschlandflagge
deutschland gab es in diesem sinne nicht
sondern es war ja eine der
hauptforderung eine deutsche einheit
sondern das war die fahne der
freiheitskämpfer derer die sich
eingesetzt haben für meinungsfreiheit
pressefreiheit demokratie und einheit
die wurde dann in den großen festzug von
neustadt hier hoch zum hambacher schloss
getragen und dann auf dem turm eben
aufgepflanzt als freiheitssymbol 30.000
menschen folgten dem ruf hinauf hinauf
zum schloss
weil politische versammlungen damals
verboten waren taten die pfälzer das
einzig richtige sie machten aus ihrer
protestaktion ein fest mit buden musik
und karussell hinauf hinauf zum schloss
heißt auch die dauerausstellung am
originalschauplatz die stiftung
hambacher schloss thematisiert die
geschehnisse rund um das hambacher fest
schulklassen touristen aus aller welt
90.000 besucher kommen pro jahr in die
ausstellung eine erlebniswelt zur
geschichte der demokratie und deren
ursprung hambacher fest lange zeit war
das schloss eine ruine bevor es 2008
nach umfangreichen
modernisierungsmaßnahmen wieder eröffnet
wurde
seither hat es sich zu einem
besuchermagneten an der weinstraße
entwickelt